i have not seen you vin since uh super
bowl 2020 when we were talking about the
big trailer release
and this everybody was so hyped because
the film was about to come out
what oh
how excited are you to finally be able
to exhale a little bit and know that
that we're going to get this we are
going to get this film
we're going to get this film um michelle
i felt i got to tell you i felt um
when we had to push the movie i felt
like i was
letting everyone down a little bit what
yeah i don't i mean
just on a personal level because i had
heard so much excitement and people
saying
we need this movie we can't wait to have
this movie i i've had people say
you know the only time i see family is
when we go to fast and furious you know
i always take it
serious and it means something to me so
there was a little part of me that felt
you know when we actually had to push
the movie
uh and it was the right thing to do but
the little part of me was like i'm
letting people down
well let me tell everybody at home this
you didn't let anybody down
because this new trailer my friend
brother against brother this should be
interesting
but could you kill him
[Applause]
okay so here's the thing ben i felt like
i was a little bit in the franchise
because they send this
this this email they're like watch it
within 90 minutes and it's
or it's gonna go away and i'm like
so i'm watching it and then i'm like i
gotta watch this again oh my god
and i'm like just when i thought i'd
seen it all i got flying cars and
magnets come on
you know it god works in mysterious ways
you i i never realized while i was
making the movie back in 2019
i never realized that we were making a
movie
that was going to bring people back
to the theatrical experience and now
with all that we've gone through what
we've
lost is being entertained together as a
community as
as as an audience as one body um
that that unifying thing that happens
when we go to the movie theater
and we are entertained as an audience
and
i mean there's so many reasons why this
is fitting because
y'all did the damn thing from what i've
seen now two big trailers
and number two this is the 20th
anniversary of this franchise
you know this year is the 20th
anniversary of this franchise can you
even wrap your brain around that vin
that you guys have been doing this for
20 years
i cannot tell you
how grateful i am
to be a part of something
that has been adopted by the world in
the way that it has
that two decades after that first car
race
we are here about to open up fast nine
all right all i can say is
blessed humbled and grateful one of the
things that i know that i love about
this franchise so much
you know through the years and the later
movies is how you all still
um managed to find the spirit of paul
and weave it through the movies
and i saw in the trailer you're gonna do
it again in this ninth
installment um you know
what do we have to look forward to and
to be able to celebrate brian o'connor
still in this movie
there's not a day that we filmed
it's not a moment of thought and
creation
that his spirit isn't with us
he makes
he brings a spirituality to the
franchise
that we all feel and
i can't i can't i can't think about a
fast and furious
without him being a part of it in one
way or another
absolutely absolutely and it's the right
decision to make
you got the right director back for this
one but by the way justin said
then never let me leave the franchise
because i talked to him almost every day
about everything so he never let me
leave the franchise
it's so true if he wasn't doing the
franchise
he had to direct the dodge commercial he
was not i was not going to let him
i had you know it's a harrowing
experience
to think as you could imagine you said
it's two decades it's
it's a 20-year anniversary imagine
the um the task
of wrapping up this mythology with
fast10
you know you want every
soldier on the battlefield you want
every
uh artistic ally you can muster up to
to to make that happen let me end with
this
ben there's a moment in the trailer
where the end of dom toretto is teased
can you imagine an end to dom toretto i
don't know if you could leave him
i don't know if you can leave him i
don't know i don't know if you could
leave him
i love you that's everything
wow it is
yeah um
bittersweet will be the the final
chapter
[Music]
bittersweet
you